good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy thursday or is
what i'm calling summer thursdays
you know we're not ready for it yet but
zuma is one of today's sponsors but this
isn't a read it's just letting you know
that today is a thumb thursday summa
thursdays let's jot that down they can't
ever sponsor any other day of the week
100 100 i'm sending it to legal now love
it they're the new thursday boots
thursday boots walk so thuma could run
um happy thursday jax we did it you know
we definitely had a leg up as it was a
short week but we made it to thursday
nonetheless which is just oh so exciting
this week has been jam-packed already
including but not limited to our episode
of breaking bread last night and
speaking of our episode of breaking
bread you were telling me that you
couldn't find one of like your little
tech gadgets is that on the floor right
there
your adapter i don't think so no that's
like for the computer i'll just have to
order one of the new one and then it'll
turn up one second of course of course
the new one of course of course once the
new one is received the old one will
show itself
it will present itself that's so true
um last night i watched your house
beverly hills we're going to do a tv
recap but it's been like on my mind
do you know what i mean and i read brian
moylan's review i've like been bad with
keeping up with them it was so on point
like it was just because i've started to
get and i also caught up on southern
charm and i'm starting to get like so
frustrated with some of these shows
because it's like you're all wrong and
dumb yeah and i can't really like
watching everyone like gaslight
sutton watching everyone be so mean to
craig like literally gaslighting craig
into thinking he has something going on
with naomi when he doesn't like i can't
watch these shows like i'm getting too
personally invested and offended like
for real okay i'm gonna separate
southern charm and
housewives because i agree with you
about housewives it's like there's
always two things happening in the show
it's like
they're all gaining up on someone and
they all think they're so right and
they're actually so wrong and then you
watch it and the audience reaction is
like so angry at these people yet they
never learn or change their way so we
just like keep watching the wrong things
happening and it's because like that
core group which is like lisa erica kyle
well not teddy anymore dorit and teddy
they were like the foxy five whatever
they call themselves like they're all
toxic gang mentality and they all just
believe what the other believes and
they're all [ __ ] wrong i don't know
who's leading them but that person is
dumb and wrong
yeah
yeah we'll get into the recap but it's
been just like on my mind yeah i'm very
the word
just like meh
right about housewives in general and
that's what brian moreland's review was
about he's like we got these two clips
early sneak peeks and the internet blew
up literally people calling on netflix
to cancel kyle's show like from this one
clip
and it's like not only is bravo like
really click baiting us but it's like
there's nothing really there like yes
what kyle said about the miscarriage
thing was like so awful and the next
night they went to dinner and she
apologized like you don't have to run to
netflix to cancel her show like calm
down yeah so it's just like they're
baiting us and then honestly while that
sounds like good marketing it's just
we're all feeling like let down after
the episode right yeah and also like
last week was a two week it ended in the
middle of an event this week it ended in
the middle of event it's like if you
just finished one event and started on a
new day then we could finish the next
event and start the next episode on a
new day no i it's really not that
complicated like that [ __ ] bothers me so
[ __ ] much like it's like when they
would end the bachelor in the middle of
a rose ceremony
like
and you know what i think that's what
i'm feeling like that bachelor angst
like that object of like wasting my time
yeah no i'm getting there too with
housewives and that will be a very sad
day when we arrive
and stop watching conclusions no i know
i mean i feel like i'm definitely like
pulling back i haven't started dubai i
started ultimate girls trip and i really
couldn't get past like the first two
episodes and i've not nary a desire to
pick it up again you know
i think i'm growing up i mean all good
things must come to an end nothing lasts
forever
it's been a really good run not saying
that it's over yet but like we can all
feel that
it's just
not giving what it used to give and i
feel like the people who like live or
housewives like it's just getting like
toxic and sad yeah sad agreed i'm like
i'm over it but i will continue watching
certain franchises i don't think i'll be
this is a preliminary conversation yeah
i'll probably keep watching for a few
maybe even years while complaining about
it but like it used to give us life
serotonin like
and i do think some of those moments
still exist i think potomac is really
like one of the better franchises
and the thing is like crazy things keep
happening but it's like nothing can
shock you we're all very desensitized
desensitized you'll see a clip and it's
like really nothing nothing shocks me
anymore yeah i mean i guess after all
that we've been through theresa gen shaw
eric jane the leg but even all of that
like even gen shop
it didn't really give this last season
no it gave nothing
i blame the other women too for not like
allowing it any space to give yeah it's
just really the craziest things keep
happening and still it's falls flat yeah
so we will talk about that at the end of
the show in the tv recap segment um and
just tell me what's going on with you
jax how's rolled of course first things
first so good so busy so obsessed with
me so obsessed with you yeah he really
really misses you he's been calling me
like every day like claudia sing for
amazing for me and i'm like again rolled
okay yeah he loves music
man of taste man of taste and he loves
his auntie what can you say man of taste
also today's livia's birthday so olivia
if you're watching happy birthday and
everyone go go we should live a happy
birthday what about a song for your
sister
oh i could impossible
happy birth
you know what i think i'm gonna go with
actually this tv one version you know
what that one that was forced on us
because of copyright issues and it
[ __ ] slaps
five
six
five six happy birthday to ya
happy birthday happy birthday to ya
happy birthday
uh olivia
happy birthday you look great
for being 28 just kidding you're 31 you
are an old [ __ ] but i still love you
even when you act like a witch because
you're olivia you are my oldest sister
and my favorite sister who is 31.
that was really cute yep i [ __ ] love
that song like you you can find me in
the club like losing yeah like the way
he just like the soul the rhythm i'm
like yeah stevie get it what are the
lyrics other than happy
oh yeah so when's the one away yeah
yeah there is and when you hear it you
don't realize you're listening happy
birthday until yeah it's important to
wait away
to dead with obey
those words
i love that song
thank you stevie
tv and speaking of
birthdays i know claudia's birthday is
in three days she's really not been
speaking about it she has nary a plan
everyone's like waiting not i mean i'm
around but most other people are just
like waiting to see what you're gonna do
where we need to be so i have nothing
planned
and that's because like i'm just like
real i'm [ __ ] done with having a
birthday in the summer oh i'm so done
with it like it's not fair it's the
summer in the city no one is around on
weekends so i'm like okay should i plan
a party like in the hamptons okay but
it's not everyone's in the hamptons some
people are traveling some people at the
jersey shore like
it's just like a lose-lose and i've
decided that this is the last year i
will be celebrating my birthday on july
10th
you can find me on my half birthday next
year i'm throwing a winter wonderland
themed bash
january 10th and from here on out my
half birthday is my regular birthday i
have declared this my final summer
birthday like i'm [ __ ] done okay i'll
believe it when i see it if that's okay
sure no like just please remind me like
i never really thought to like
officially reschedule my birthday and i
wish i had done it this year yeah but
you could always like take a trip you
really would even if everyone was in the
city like you want to throw a party no
these parties are just i just want
people to like be around like i can't
explain it yeah i just feel forgotten
and left behind well i'm old i'm here
for you i know i know is that not enough
it's it's not but i love you so much i
know
so yeah i'm just like over it completely
and not even a dinner do you want to go
to dinner i mean like i could always eat
it's not about that you know yeah it's
about the principal
yeah and it's about like literally
everyone leaving me on my birthday
anyone can understand about the
principal it's me because you're a
principled girly i am
so i really don't want to talk about it
to be honest like marco keeps calling me
like what's the plan like shut up margo
i don't [ __ ] know okay and you
calling me it's not gonna make me plan
something sooner okay but then you just
if you continue with this energy and
like really just don't make a big deal
out of your birthday that's fine but
sometimes like you do this and then all
of a sudden it's like i'm having a party
everyone starts at eight o'clock see you
there no i mean because if there was
ever a time for a party i would have
done it tonight
no that's your mistake well i'm not
doing a party like please i really want
to talk about this honestly like
we just move on let's talk about your
birthday okay what are you gonna be
doing
i think i'm gonna have a big party
because i'm turning 30.
30 40 and thriving yeah either a big
party or a big trip you should throw a
party that's what i'm thinking how
exciting yeah
it could be join
would you mind
you could join my birthday in general
you know i'm down for a fall winter
moment like i'm just done yeah i'm done
like people with summer birthdays will
know like you want to celebrate yourself
but like it's literally impossible so
like you're for like honestly can we
please change the subject like sure i
understand it's i understand okay do you
want to jump right in we have a lot to
do today we're actually like doing photo
shoot photo shoot photo shoots like like
oh my god being a model is like really
challenging you know it is because
everyone thinks like oh man you're just
like beautiful and dumb you just stand
there and look pretty right and like
they don't not only do i not realize how
much work goes into it but like how like
literally educated i am and like i'm a
genius yeah and i feel like you want to
spend your time like proving to everyone
how smart you are right like getting
more degrees getting nobel peace prizes
writing books writing books like reading
books essays yeah short stories it's
just hard you know and the hardest part
is like nobody feels bad for you because
you're a model and like nobody looks at
me and is like oh she must be devastated
i mean she laura has a perfect body and
face and hair like no one thinks that so
it's hard for sure i'm sorry you're
going through that we're both going
through it we're both we're both models
today so before we get into our modeling
yeah let's just do this little show we
do let's dive into the fast five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
and they are good stories everyone so
the sooner we dive in the better and
they're good
sponsors
let me be thumb that's right thuma your
bedroom deserves a refresh and now is
the perfect time to elevate the most
important room in your home with zuma
zuma practices an intentional less is
more design philosophy for the bedroom
with clean lines subtle curves and
lifestyle enhancing details thumb proves
that simplicity is the truest form of
sophistication so introducing the bed by
thuma handcrafted from eco-friendly high
quality upcycled wood you'll find
beautiful unique variations in natural
grain the minimalist design featuring
japanese joinery helps elevate any space
it's super supportive for your mattress
it's breathable and it's made to
naturally minimize noise and create any
space made for how you live the bed by
zuma is backed with a lifetime warranty
it ships right to your door in three
easy to maneuver boxes and takes about
five minutes to assemble with no tools
required thank god for thuma
hi say that again thank god for
thumbnail no no tools required
along with the bed they also offer other
bedroom essentials that elevate bedtime
like the nightstand the side table table
and the tray that are perfect
complements to the bed suma is also
working with one tree planted to plant
one tree for every bed and nightstand
sold all their essentials are green
guard gold certified create that feeling
of checking into your favorite boutique
hotel suite but at home with the bed by
thuma and now go to thuma dot co slash
toast to receive a 25 credit towards
your purchase of the bed plus free
shipping in the continental us go to
thuma dot co slash toast that's thuma t
h u m a dot c o slash toast for 25
credit today's episode is also brought
to you by bowling branch bowling branch
uses 100 best or organic cotton threads
on earth for superior softness and a
better night's sleep for your sheets one
thing about us we are bowling branch
girlies the pillowcases the fitted sheet
the duvet cover the throw blankets the
bedroom accessories everything we have
is from roland branch long before they
were a sponsor you need to refresh your
bed and
you need bowling brand check it just
really it's one of those things i don't
really feel like i have to explain even
though i'm literally being paid to
explain you know so the signature sheet
collection that's what jackie and i both
have it comes in nine neutral colors in
all the sizes from twin up to california
king you'll feel the difference
immediately of their iconic signature
sheets they're 100 free from toxins
their sheets fit the deepest of
mattresses and they're labeled with top
and bottom tags literally last night i
realized my fitted sheet was on wrong
and i made ben get out of bed at
midnight and turn the lights on and i
was like ben find the tag like someone
ben had put it on like sofa cocked and
he doesn't know about the tag ben just
literally find the tag watch the morning
toes it took one second to flip the
thing and i knew i was right like i just
knew i got in bed i'm like i don't think
this sheet is on right yeah but that's
game-changing technology
literally elon musk can never
best of all bowling branch gives you a
30-night risk-free trial with free
shipping and returns on all orders
their annual summer event is starting
soon but bowling branch is giving our
listeners exclusive early access before
anyone else to the 20 off with the promo
code toast at bowlingbranch.com it's
their best offer of the year before the
holidays so act now bowlin branch
b-o-l-l-a-n-d branch dot com promo code
toast for that 20 off
great okay our first story some justice
news cheer star jerry harris was
sentenced to 12 years in his child
pornography case
jerry harris of netflix's cheer has been
sentenced to 12 years behind bars in the
child pornography case he was in court
on wednesday where a string of his
friends and supporters read statements
about the disgraced reality star's
character anyone notable like from the
show oh i'm not sure tmz doesn't specify
after the lengthy hearing the judge
announced the 12-year sentence fed
source tells tmz that he has been
ordered into eight years to pay 35
thousand dollars into a vaaa crime
victims fund along with courts
supervised released after imprisonment
he was facing up to 50 years behind bars
after pleading guilty to one count of
receipt of child pornography and one
count of traveling with the intent to
engage in illicit sexual conduct federal
prosecutors recommended harris spent 15
years locked away and they settled on
12. also
his attorney released a statement this
morning saying jerry is exceedingly
grateful for judge shaw's recognition of
his humanity worthiness rehabilitative
potential while jerry has a difficult
road ah ahead of him his uncompromising
spirit and strength has carried him
through the challenging times before he
has nothing but empathy and remorse for
the people he has harmed and hopes that
the proceeding provided them some peace
this is like i feel like tyra banks you
know we were rooting for you we were all
rooting for you how could you yeah and
this jerry thing like you know me i'm
such a justice girly like i'm always
seeking out justice and
updates on the story just like make me
so sad do you know what i mean like it's
not like a good justice galen maxwell
feeling do you know what i mean yeah
and i don't know if that's because like
the the front he put on on the show was
like great acting because he really was
like this
nice guy but like i don't know and i
know i'm wrong for feeling that i'm
wrong for saying it but it just makes me
sad like i can't really explain why yeah
i mean the whole thing is really sad
it's very sad for the kids that he
abused and if you watch the second
season of cheer they really get a chance
to tell their story and you see how like
ongoing and manipulative
the whole situation was which is just so
shocking like i can't see jerry doing
that but he did right you just never
know who people really are it's so true
and that's like when you watch reality
tv especially when you watch reality tv
because you think oh i see everything
about you and i think even in more
innocuous cases where it's like this
person seems mean but like they're not
or they seem nice but they're not yeah
this person seems like you know the most
lovable person on the planet but he's
actually a child molesting monster right
it's so crazy and like that's the lesson
like you literally know nothing about
the people you watch yeah or the people
that you follow or you don't look up to
if you don't know them as true people in
your life it's so true
so hopefully the 12 years you know
rehabilitates him i guess yeah i don't
know i'm just like
this is like a sick story you know yeah
it's very sad all around and
justice has been served justice has been
served and i'm glad that the
his victims were able to
find some pieces i guess
it's just like it's been a crazy ride
yeah for like when we started cheer till
now and where do we go from here i mean
they did cheer season two when this was
still happening so but there is no more
cheer there is no more no like all the
kids graduated there's not a third
season you know that for sure no season
yes but they're doing cheer on tour so
like all the girls who graduated who are
not really eligible to be like athletes
anymore are full-fledged athletes
they're on tour it's i think it's in new
york like literally this weekend i was
looking like maybe should i go to a
concert and i think it's in new york
this weekend oh that's good you should
go no
no no well that's good for them even
though this felt like when you watched
season two of cheer it felt like a show
that was a curse
yeah like maybe it would have been best
if they left it just at one season no
but like even season one
season two just showed like the effects
of like really quick worldwide fame
and how everybody struggled and handled
it differently
but
i don't think just doing season one
would have stopped any of the other
things from happening yeah yeah
that's true like everyone was just so
down like monica
monica ladarius was obviously going
through something oh my god yeah um
gabby was queen yeah queen but she had
had fame before yesterday and that might
have been the difference yeah that's
actually really true
and morgan seems well but she wasn't on
season two like she kind of got in and
out yeah but she's on the tour now great
yeah so i think the tour was like a nice
iteration of like what to do next
but yeah
yeah
justice has been served are you ready
for our next story some shocking news
from elon's camp
elon musk welcomed twins with a top
executive at one of his companies just
before his second child with grimes was
born
so last night it emerged that elon
quietly welcomed twins with siobhan
zillas who was one of his top executives
um
last year a new report from business
insider claims according to court
documents obtained by the outlet the
mobile expanded his family with neural
siobhan in november 2021
business insider reports that elon and
siobhan filed a petition to change the
twins name in order to have their
father's last name and contain their
mother's last name as part of their
middle name
sounds like they're just they're not
contentious they're like working
together yeah and that like he has
welcomed these what's neuro link
one of his companies got it
um the order was approved by a texas
judge in may but the kids first names
remain unknown so good leave them alone
like they're kids oh of course but it's
always fun to hear what elon's going to
name
12 95 also exit dark side royale um what
that's the second baby with grimes
that's the name the daughter extra dark
side rail it's a
it's a digit that i don't know how to
pronounce the a and the e touching i
definitely don't know right this is um
the woman
she's cute
um her friends call her shiv so the
these kids so he has two kids with
grimes one with shiv and then five
minutes two is shiv they're twins oh
right oh my god so it's four four and
then five other living children with his
og wife who started it all but do you
know that elon has a girlfriend right
now
an actress isn't it grimes no him and
grimes are not together and we knew that
but he's dating this actress natasha
bassett who played brittany in the
lifetime talk about brittany
okay here's the thing like does elon
musk literally like do women's fertility
tests before he goes out with them just
to ensure that they can get pregnant
immediately if not sooner like i've
never seen such strong sperm and such
fertile women like you would think but
just by looking at this situation like
getting pregnant is incredibly easy and
we all know it's not well grimes had a
baby via surrogate oh the second one is
the first the second one okay um
so but i think they're like setting out
to have children i i don't know the
nature of these two's relationship and
or the pregnancy but
i think like he's interested in in
repopulating and repopulating the earth
i mean it's a lot of kids it's giving
like you know like religious you know
like really religious people only like
super religious people have like nine
kids yeah i can't believe he has nine
kids and there's speculation that he is
also the father of amber heard's child
which would bring it to an even
double digits which is so crazy and he
had one son who passed away his first
son died of sids oh my god um
back in 2002 i think oh that's so sad
two thousand
and two yeah i feel like that like
could be a reason why someone has a lot
of kids perhaps oh that's so sad i
didn't know that yeah
um okay well
that's
nine maybe ten he's literally going to
be the star of the next cheaper rather
dozen yeah he's john goslin he's john
gosselin and steve martin yeah
um
also like it's i think that you know
he's probably been like
doing this privately i don't think he
was like hiding anything i wonder how
they found out maybe the court documents
but i wonder if like him and shiv are
gonna oh no he has a different
girlfriend right i really can't keep up
the seven hus the seven wives of elon
musk i know but whenever like i hear
about elon like doing his thing out in
the world i just think of like go elon
go
elon out there in the world doing his
thing i'm just like obviously it's not
surprising that he like gets so many
women because he's
um a billionaire many times over but
like you know like we saw him on snl
like he's kind of like quirky and like
weird so it's just like
he also has game obviously the money
helps immensely and the smarts
imagine
that being really smart also sometimes
makes you like a little socially
inept yeah and that's what when i
watched him on snl i'm like oh he has
that like really smart
personality trait where like you're a
little weird mm-hmm so
i guess just something cute about him he
sleeps in the bedroom he slays well
congratulations family's growing family
is great i wonder how all the different
like moms feel about you know the other
ones yeah
it's like elon's wives club yeah no it's
literally like a documentary in the
making
yeah
um mazel mazel
i can't think of the name shiv or
siobhan without thinking of just
succession yeah i know it's like a name
that i hate because i hate that [ __ ]
you know yeah that's such a cute little
giggle like a little girl because you
hate that
[ __ ] yeah
i
might my succession like um
fire in your heart my fire has
extinguished 12 yeah for now you know it
doesn't bring up the like the visceral
emotions that it once did when it comes
back i'm sure it will i'm on succession
talk
which is fan edits of like different
characters like people think you know
tom and cousin greg are like in love um
and then i also see a lot of uh
reenactments so like i'm i'm always
thinking of succession what do you mean
by reenactment there's like this
tick-tocking couple
out of their couple or brother and
sister like these two people on
tick-tock they were like if everyday
life was succession and they edit their
videos like of like them eating
breakfast with like the succession vibe
okay and it's like cute and funny that's
not as weird as i thought it was going
to be no yeah i definitely made it i
thought it was going to be like um
larping
no no no no no then we leave the larping
to you thank you i was on the phone with
snitch the other night and i was so hard
i know and i think she called me
i don't know but jump right sorry i was
larping very hard and i said to her you
know larping is quite exhausting like i
was getting so fatigued and she said
what's larping
like marta why don't you just say i hate
your show no and so i said
oh it's called live action role play and
she thought about it she was like oh
that's exactly what you do right with
the dogs with the babies with literally
the counselors yeah
so i believe margaret doesn't know what
larping is i mean i shouldn't be
surprised now she knows
now she knows are you ready for our next
story which i think is going to cheer
you right up mm-hmm not that you're
upset yeah do i actually i'm having a
case of the birthday blues yeah but i
think whatever your ailment is everyone
out there this is going to cure it jason
mamoa and isa gonzalez were spotted at
the same hot spots week after their
alleged breakup oh good good good good
jason mamoa and aza gonzalez may not be
over just yet as the pair were seen
hanging out at the same two hot spots in
london on tuesday plus the fact that
their recent x's and they're in the same
city is bizarre bodes well
the stars exited the venue separately
and only minutes apart and we're inside
over the same period people reports okay
you guys of course like they just didn't
want to get like a photo op because
they're obviously just like working
through some things
but i so support these two getting back
together also speaking of people getting
back together uh devin booker and
kendall jenner are 100 back together did
they ever break up yes but like they
were trotting around the hamptons
together all weekend
oh cute like together
it means it's true they're back together
guys you heard it here first and so i
just i'm loving this trend of
celebrities getting back with their exes
like you know what sometimes like if it
works it works it's like that show the
one that got away even though they broke
up two days ago yeah
i mean did they even break up yeah no i
don't really get the point of getting
back with someone who you broke up with
like two days ago like what did you
learn in those two days about like why'd
you have to break up right why couldn't
you just say like i'm going home for two
days but this was what like two weeks
that we
spoke about jason momoa and asa gonzalez
yeah but you know what's so crazy
when i read this story it would
i it was like i was like oh yeah we did
talk about that but i had completely
forgotten about us reporting on this
because they're like so to themselves
you know they're not like thirst
monsters it's giving like belle and
chris rock oh lake rock lake rock
uh yeah i'm happy for them i wish jason
mamoa you know i love that we got to see
jason mamoa in his like
loyal husband era but now also in his
hottest man alive like date anyone who
you would prefer to era yes give you a
guy who could do both and that's just my
mama you know this couple is just so
wonderful yeah it's like if i was a
female in hollywood i would i'd want to
date him if i was a male in hollywood
i'd want to date her yeah hence they
should be together like
but you know what's funny remember those
pictures of aza gonzalez making out with
timothy shalamy in a pool
yes
like
i don't know how you could like
be
into both like they're literally polar
opposites
and like i just imagine like the
experience of rolling around in a bed
with timothy shalom is incredibly
different than the experience of rolling
around in about with jason mama yeah but
that's on physics you know that's not
even a subjective statement no it's
literal science yeah trust the science
that's what i'm telling you i'm
literally a scientist and a model
you love to be both that's like elon
totally
um and i just like wonder like what it's
like to like you know even get a hug
from jason mama like it must be like an
overwhelming experience out of body yeah
you know like in these books that i read
that are like spicy they always like
describe the man as literally jason
momoa not the hair but just like the
body type the build the build it's like
you've never seen someone so big and
strong in your life and you're like
people like that don't exist but here
they are they do yeah
and asa gonzalez is experiencing that
i'm really happy for her me too i hope
they're having a whirlwind romance but
next time just walk out of the hot spot
together please so we can have a photo
like give us something like a hard time
some of us are experiencing summer
birthdays like we need this to get to
move on okay now it's been a hard year
it's been a long day's night and we
cannot be working like a dog
i really have you know what song i've
heard on tik tok a lot
reels that i like i like the beat
you ain't nothing butter dog okay
what song is it it's that doji cat for
the elvis soundtrack it's like a town
dog by elvis
well actually by big mama thornton um
but reimagined by doja
it's such a good song i've only heard
that one part i i keep you should listen
go listen to it you should listen to the
elvis soundtrack i won't do it because i
want to experience the songs in the
movie oh because casey musgraves is on
it mark ronson was a bit was like a
producer on a lot of the songs dojo
what's a song called dog yeah
or is it called vegas vegas yeah okay
let me oh let me just don't play it
copyright no i know i'm just gonna save
it to my spotify thank you okay
continuing on yep
to our fourth story yeah um yes um but i
actually have something to say
yeah go ahead the fourth story is
brought to you by pear eyewear
you are a unique mash-up of all your
favorite things and there's a multitude
of ways to express yourself so celebrate
all that you are and explore who you can
be with customizable prescription
glasses from pear eyewear pear eyewear
lets you change your glasses like you
change your clothes so there's no reason
why like literally just because you have
glasses you have to wear the same pair
every single day pear is genius because
they are letting you change up the style
the color the design the pattern of your
glasses to go with your outfit and
here's how it works
choose your um you can get started by
choosing your base frame with the
options from square to cat eye whatever
style fits your face and then every
frame that you buy comes in six
different color ways including classic
black to the remixed blue tortoise so
then you'll pick your top frames and
build a collection to match your
personality so you could just snap on
snap off your red pair your blue pair oh
i'm wearing brown let me get my beige
ones like your glasses should should be
a fun accessory not just like this thing
you have to wear the same of every
single day it's really smart you can get
glasses that are as unique as you are
one pair that comes in infinite styles
starting at just sixty dollars so go to
pear eyewear dot com slash toast for
fifteen percent off your first purchase
that's fifteen percent off at p a i r i
wear dot com slash toast pair spelled p
a i r pair eyewear dot com slash toast
gorgeous our next story a little movie
news james cameron doesn't want
audiences whining over the length of
avatar too he says they binge watch tv
for eight hours facts the new avatar
sequel is here after 13 years and it is
three hours long but director james
cameron doesn't want to hear any
complaints and he's talking to you no i
know he's talking to claudia ashrae when
he said quote i don't want anybody
whining about the link when what length
when they sit and binge watch television
for eight hours it's like give me a
[ __ ] break i've watched my kids sit
and do five one hour episodes in a row
here's the big social paradigm shift
that has to happen it's okay to get up
and go pee
um
is he talking about like in the theater
because i agree with him like we
sometimes it's crazy if you actually
think about like oh i watched a whole
season or whatever this weekend and it's
like literally 22 one hour episodes like
it's psychotic so i get what he's saying
but like you were asking me to go to a
theater like leave my house for three
hours like that's asking a lot no and
yeah i do have to get up and go pee but
we're not going to pause as a theater
and it's like i also want to refresh my
snacks after one and a half that's why
the intermission is a lost art that
should be brought back the problem with
intermission though is the lines
everybody's going at the same time also
p and to e the problem with intermission
is that like especially as it pertains
to broadway shows like it makes shows
longer than they need to be yeah because
intermission's too long because also the
lines get so long and then you have to
game out intermission i'm gonna get
there five minutes before intermission
i'm gonna beat the line you know what i
have like kind of a good idea tell me if
you
maybe i shouldn't say it like i think
it's really good
okay for movies in like at the theater
that are over two hours long
you should have like an app like
connected to the theater where like you
are need to pause like to get snacks or
go to the bathroom and you just click
like i'm ready to pause and when enough
people in the theater like
30 of the audience are ready to pause
like we take a collective pause that's
really nice it could just be something
on the chair sure you know what i mean
were they tally okay so let's say a
theater seats 50 people and there's 30
people in the theater so once 10 of them
have to go to the bathroom like we
should all pause i like that but for a
max of five minutes like you can't it's
not an indefinite pause can you tell
people go to the bathroom in five
minutes but if someone has to drop a
dude
if you have to drop a juice like you
shouldn't go to the movies okay you need
a different button we need number one
and number two on both arms like a five
minute break or a ten minute break and i
don't think like if i was watching a
movie like and i didn't have to pee
which by the way i could always pee so i
wouldn't be mad if they paused the movie
and i had to just wait five minutes for
everyone to like go back i don't think
i'd be that pissed i could be getting
nice like get up stretch check my phone
check my phone like i think that's like
maybe one of the best ideas i've
literally ever had yeah i think would
require a lot of money to
install in each chair right it's almost
like um like these big chains and movie
theaters have money it's been a few hard
years but they're always doing dumb
things at the theater like remember like
they're always doing dumb things yeah
and they could install like one good
feature
i mean my [ __ ] local movie theater
doesn't even have a foundation they're
like literally buying bottles from
dwayne reed and selling it at the
counter it's like so upsetting i like
bottles so you can't go by me
i hate hate except i don't like the big
bottle because then it loses its fizz
unless you were to drink the whole thing
at once uh that's fair but that's the
big bottle is more for like a family
barbecue
like i i don't like you know when it's a
half done bottle and i have to pour
myself a cup from it
of course not but i will still drink it
fresh but you throw some ice in there
some lemon slices like it does fizz it
back to life a little bit you know no it
just distracts you from the lack of fizz
100
um
okay cool
cool or we could just all watch movies
at home and have independence i do feel
like whenever we report on james cameron
which is like a bi-yearly event yeah
he's always yelling at us i kind of like
his energy me too like [ __ ] off like i'm
a genius and you think you know better
but you don't so like either watch my
movie you're down and watch the movie
and you're gonna like it you're gonna
watch it and you're gonna like it yeah
he's giving like strict dad energy and
i'm here for it i'm here too like he
works years on his art and sometimes
like society needs a good [ __ ] yell
yelling session because we are out of
control yeah complaining about
everything meanwhile you do sit and
on your couch and watch eight hours
straight no and you know what i
appreciate him saying this because you
know what now i will not be seeing
avatar and i appreciate like a director
who is oh can i have a sip of that yeah
let me just take one but also what i was
going to say this story is a good
opportunity for me and claudia to let
you know that we never saw avatar um you
didn't i don't know like why you're
speaking for me because i never saw
avatar and i just think it's a fun fact
about me you're not like other girls i'm
not you know like everyone in the world
saw avatar was the biggest movie of all
time yet not me no because you're just
more into like indie alternative films
yeah i'm just like you're just taking a
long time to take that
stream because i'm just i'm so
interesting yeah that's the avatar i did
see avatar um
i thought you were interesting like me i
did see avatar i didn't understand like
most of it but i did enjoy it
um but i don't think i need to see the
sequel well there's actually going to be
like four sequels and they've already
shot um
the second movie in the third movie i'm
so happy and then there's gonna be two
more and james said that he's open to
having someone else direct the last two
movies all right i'll do it i'll do it
he's done i'm happy for zoe saldana like
she must be raking it in because after
the first avatar she like never worked
again because she probably made it
because she's so much money have to
and then she like got to do this project
again
yeah
same amount of money and again it's like
every
there are like certain actresses in
hollywood who
like got in on a franchise and never had
to work again cameron diaz shrek
i knew that's what you're gonna say
you're like so annoying
in the way you are
i didn't do anything and now i'm not
giving you your coffee back it's just
because i'm the only person who didn't
see avatar
no just i do need to take the edge off
it's just because you're the only person
i actually talk to and so you always
know what i'm gonna say
that's true yeah so why don't you like
not spoil it for everyone else because i
have so much to give okay
okay fine and i just wanted to say one
more thing oh kate winslet is in avatar
too i guess james likes working with her
she wasn't in avatar once she's a
titanic girly yeah don't forget about
titanic oh my god i forgot to tell you
you know what i'm supposed to do tonight
see titanic no see titanic which brian
got us tickets for he's like it's like a
parody it's like a i really didn't don't
know what it was about but i was like
excited to go it's like a live show okay
um and they canceled tonight's
performance how
explain the show further you can't just
say titanic parody it's titanic i think
it's like a
i mean if it's brian got the ticket so i
think it's like a like a gay sassy drag
queen titanic
i think i honestly don't know i didn't
want to look it up because i just wanted
to like go and brian was like it's
loosely based off titanic
and it's hilarious titanic the movie or
titanic the ship
they're the same thing no but like it's
it's not going to be about
jack no it's not
no i think it is
okay it's spelled like unique titanic i
see i see what it's about i'm like i was
really upset brian said because of covid
like what does that even mean
what does that even mean when the music
of celine dion makes sweet canadian love
with the 11 time oscar winning film
titanic you get titanique a musical
celebration that turns one of the
greatest love stories of all time okay
so it is jack and rose and sorry i knew
it was set to the soundtrack of celine
dion which is why brian brought tickets
into a hysterical and joyful slay fest
want to find out what really happened to
jack and rose on that fateful night our
story begins when celine dion hijacks
the titanic museum tour and enchants the
audience with her totally wild take
recharting the course of titanic's
beloved moments and characters with her
iconic song catalog featuring powerhouse
voices and show-stopping numbers
titanique is a one-of-a-kind musical
voyage bursting with nostalgia and
hearts doesn't that sound so good yes
and so like literally i had it in my
calendar for weeks and yesterday brian
sent me a screenshot they sent out an
email like covid by like what i'm so
upset
performance update in accordance with
our code protocols and safety of our
guests they will not be performing july
6th through 12th through 10th i guess
because someone had probably got
questions no they coveted sent to memo
site i'm coming july 6th through 10th
so everyone stay away so i had to
research that's why they have
understudies even if like a couple no
but if if somebody had coven like expose
everyone in the company
yeah yeah i'm just upset
um
and i've made other plans but it was
upsetting because like i was really
looking forward to this yeah you need to
go and let me know how it is titanic
now are you am i going to get my coffee
back oh i thought you like gave it to me
because like you don't share lips i
thought it was like mine now yeah that's
why you took one final sip okay and it's
mostly like ice in here fine enjoy are
you ready for our fifth and final just
like gas let you into giving me my
coffee no you were right about
you're right are you ready for our fifth
and final story i really am okay because
it's like um some interesting bachelor
news which you know sounds like an
accident so rare
um
but you know that michelle and nate
broke up michelle young yes yes she was
bachelorette teacher queen teacher queen
she chose nate who was very handsome and
they broke up which i don't think we
reported on but it is always big news
when the lead breaks up with their
chosen one yeah not sure if we reported
on it but apparently when they were on
there after the final rose they got a
200 000 check
from the show to put a down payment on a
house so now we're hearing from michelle
about what she's going to do with the
money i'm sorry was that like a secret
check or on the it aired like no it
aired oh how cute yeah and we missed
that but that's just like a cute thing
and i do a nice thing that is a really
nice thing and it does set a couple up
for a success yeah not in this case but
it's just a nice thing and and i um so
do you have to give that back with the
ring so she was on an episode of ben and
ashley's podcast and they asked what
she's gonna do with the money and it's a
confusing answer but i also want to get
your take
she said that was money that was gifted
to both of us and i think that's
something that is going to be decided
how that's going to be utilized going
forward uh girly english please
for me personally i haven't officially
decided but i kind of have started
putting some different things in place
to give back to build an organization or
just promote the change that i've been
talking about i think that would be
something that i'd feel really good
about still she acknowledged it's been
an emotional time deciding what to do
with the check quote i've been crying on
the phone with one of the producers and
like can i give this money like can i
create this to give the money to
somebody else it's something that i feel
good about i know that's been the
million dollar question no pun intended
but yeah it's been a lot huh
what
it's a word salad and she obviously
doesn't know what she's gonna do with it
yet so like literally don't answer the
question yeah it's really weird also
just keep the money you know they but
they should split the money evenly yeah
but it's 200 000 after taxes it's like
100 grand so they each get 50. yeah but
then she's also throwing in you know
some charitable so she should take her
50 and start
her own charity right like you can't
force it she could say that outright
like i'm donating some of it instead of
saying a word salad i haven't officially
decided but i have kind of started
putting some different things in place
to give back
to build an organization no and that
sounds really really nice but you did
not answer the question at all no she
circumvented the question right she
circled around the question i didn't
know that they had given them a check
that's nice they should do like stuff
like that more often yeah
but even though like when someone is the
lead and they get engaged like
opportunities
give it to the person who was sent home
first on night one that's so true like
they're gonna be scraping the bottom of
the barrel with fabfitfun for the rest
of their life they already left their
job right they're gonna try it as an
influencer right it's not going to go
great unless they are a star in paradise
yeah which is so rare yeah but look at
grocery story joe that's literally his
story okay but that's one out of
literally hundreds of contestants i can
give you a handful of more but yes so um
well i guess we'll never know what
happened to the two hundred thousand
dollars yeah i just thought that was a
really like funny salary worthy answer
yeah no it was not an answer it was not
an answer an answer it was not i do want
to say i didn't listen to the episode
i'm just reading these quotes but i also
believe if she had said something
definitive it would be in here no you
read a transcription word for word of
what she said right
she obviously doesn't know what she's
going to do with the money yet i think
that's something that is going to be
decided how that's going to be utilized
going forward and i'm constantly
thinking about how things are going to
be decided how it's going to be utilized
going forward to give back you know yeah
yeah so those are the past five i wonder
if it's in both their names though or if
she really could just keep it like
oh well that's a good question too
either way um i still don't know what
she's doing with the money no and she
didn't tell us um those are the best
stories you definitely needed to know a
lot of that i do think so and let's dive
into our tv recap recapping the real
housewives of beverly hills which is
brought to you by manscaped the leader
in men's below the waist grooming the
products are so good you're gonna be
showing pride in his new bush-free yard
the products are great for female use
too you can save big and help him be the
most hygienic version of himself using
our discount code toast for 20 off and
free shipping at manscape.com so the
grooming package that we highly
recommend is the performance package 4.0
inside the package includes the
lawnmower 4.0 which is a trimmer that is
designed to reduce grooming accidents
and shave hair on loose skin thanks to
the ceramic blade and advanced skin safe
technology the trimmer also has an led
light to allow him to be super precise
it is waterproof it can be used in the
shower which means no mess around the
sink or the floor
it also has the weed whacker which is a
fine-tuned nose and ear hair trimmer it
is the best nose hair trimmer on the
market um i have to say like i'm not
like a nose hair trimmer girly but like
every now and then there's like a long
hair that like sticks out of my nose and
plucking it like oh just literally
stoned me to death it's so painful
um and so sometimes i'll shove ben's
thing like up my nose and it clears it
out like i'm not even ashamed like well
i'm a little ashamed but that's why i
bought the performance package 4.0 for
ben but like mostly for me like all
great men's products yeah the women's
steel at first i was like oh i'll just
use like some of the skin care products
and now here i am shoving things up my
nose you know
they also have um
the vegan dye free crop preserver ball
deodorant and a spray on bald ball toner
so you could keep your man's balls like
nice and clean like balls are
disgusting like dark and gross and so
manscaped is just like doing the most
out here to try and make balls like less
gross but it's really for the women you
also get two free gifts with the
performance package it's the shed travel
bag and the patented high performance
reduced chafing manscaped boxers so you
can get 20 off and free shipping with
our code toast at manscape.com that's 20
off with free shipping at manscaped.com
use code toast ladies do yourself and
your men a favor by using manscaped
great
rehoboah oh yeah so real housewives of
beverly hills before we get into like
the drama at both parties i just wanted
to say and i've been really hard on
crystal this season i actually thought
her idea of taking dory to a
self-defense class was like a really
thoughtful
nice gift and it made me like crystal
that's just what i wanted to say it's a
nice moment it was a nice moment also i
haven't watched in so long that i forgot
that i was in disliking crystal mode
yeah and in this episode she was totally
fine she took a backseat for sure she
was like neutral good so yeah that's
good and her home stuff was cute like
actually her and rob are
like actually like have a really nice
marriage what did they show us at home
um they were cooking he got home from
china talking about he's turning a book
into a play
lord the he nor [ __ ]
where the [ __ ] was i okay whatever well
they also um
showed us crystal's brother who i forgot
is like a big chinese pop star oh my god
i didn't know that yeah they mentioned
it like her first season and it was
really like never mentioned again and
then they were talking about her during
the pandemic he was in asia and he
released his album it was called
i forget but like he looked really cute
on the album cover like it was just like
i forgot about that um we got a lot of
home scenes which i really wasn't
particularly interested in but it's also
the holidays that's true yes
yes
so
garcelle's party
it was like such a hodgepodge everyone
was like wasted and i feel like we've
never seen the end of a party like
they usually just like fade out but like
literally dorit and erica were sitting
after the bar was closed after garcia
left
it was weird yeah was it a short party
or they just showed us more footage than
they normally do yeah because maybe like
the good stuff happens in the middle you
know yeah and but really juicy things
happen toward the end this time so as it
pertains to garcelle's sons there were
two instances obviously erica being like
a [ __ ] freak to her older son who's
married with four kids and who is
definitely extremely handsome um and
then yelling at her
younger son to get the [ __ ] out or [ __ ]
off get the [ __ ] out yeah and then they
keep repeating it as [ __ ] off those are
not that one is any good but those are
different things yeah and i do have to
say i
like i'm in my hating erica era i don't
think she had bad intentions like she
was really drunk i wasn't really
bothered by the the older something
because like even though it's weird or
whatever like he's a grown-ass man it's
not inappropriate
it no it's not
it's not inappropriate it's just weird
yeah it's a little inappropriate but
like it's so it's he's 30 he can handle
it yeah it's less nefarious yeah and she
was really just like having fun with him
she took it to like a little bit of an
inappropriate threesome but in the
beginning it was just like oh you're
cute son i can chalk that up to like
drunk weirdness yeah now the thing with
the younger son like
while you should never curse at a 14
year old she did think he was 16 which i
think once she found that out she knew
she was immediately wrong
but also like her tone while she was
cursing at him i think she was trying to
like help him because she was like get
the [ __ ] out of here like your mom needs
you like i don't think she was telling
him to like get away from me i think she
was like your mom's leaving why are you
still here
she didn't realize he was there to pick
up the flowers for her mom i have no
idea what she was trying to say or do i
just feel like her tone while like while
it was weird because she was cursing she
almost felt like she was trying to be
helpful and protect yeah i can't
understand what i wish not that anything
could excuse what she was doing and
maybe she can't even recall what she was
trying to do but i do wish she explained
like no what i was trying to say was
this because i genuinely don't
understand why she was telling him to
get the [ __ ] out of there i also wish
the second that she got to sutton's
party she just immediately apologized to
garcelle because garcia's now like the
more that it lingers the more she's
getting angry and then we'll probably
talk about it in a big group
and it's not like erica is going to be
so contrite with a big group around
she's still going to be her you know
herself mean self whereas she clearly in
her notion no she's wrong is ready to
apologize and it's coming in and
it was being nice for erica like hey you
ladies can i see the cavalier
and she was being soft and i just wish
like just get it out of the way like
arcelo's not an unreasonable person at
all if you just like apologize and
explain she would get over it but it's
the fact that erica hasn't called her
yet and now it's like they're at the
party she still hasn't even mentioned it
it's annoying because it's going to turn
into a thing when like these two and i
want them to get along like i just
eric is handling it incorrectly yes now
speaking of handling incorrectly is the
diana jenkins sutton kyle moment i don't
think i've actually ever seen kyle look
so poor in an episode she's usually very
in control and she showed up halfway
through the conversation and didn't
realize what a [ __ ] [ __ ] diana was
being and so she automatically took
diana's side because she only saw sutton
defending herself
and so she thought sutton was coming out
the aggressor and she wanted to diana is
positively dreadful like the hate i have
for this woman when at first she came
out i was like yes yes yes i hate her
and i thought the most telling scene was
at her house recounting the argument to
lisa rinna
yeah talk about like just flat out lying
yeah no but that's why context is
everything diana comes in and says like
she called me soulless and a
[ __ ] and it's like in response
to soulless [ __ ] things you did
right and you called her boring you said
you didn't care about her miscarriage
like
it was so frustrating and then like lisa
who wouldn't even lisa got bad
information but she probably doesn't
even care that it's bad information
because what i think works for her
what i've realized over the last couple
years about lisa rinna
is actually realized it last night and
it made sense lisa brando like always
weirdly like takes up for random people
and what i've noticed is that she is
constantly taking up for the richest
woman she like cozies up it used to be
erica it's not anymore but they built a
real friendship after that now she's
like obsessed with cr with um defending
diana
like they act like they're friends
they're not friends like they are not
friends
lisa arena is obsessed with like the
richest woman in the group and it's
always talking about it i remember last
season when they introduced sutton and
lisa was like she is rich honey and like
she went to
dolce gabbana with her was like oh my
god i love that even this ugly shirt
like she's obsessed with money that's
such an interesting point
because she was the one who brought on
sutton by the way and she was the one
who brought on diane no i thought
crystal was brought on diana yeah
well i guess the first event they went
to was harry hammond's birthday
but i think crystal and diana are closer
than diana at least i thought rina
brought diana
on i don't know why i thought that
because she showed up at um for the
first time at harry hammond's birthday
party information about elton john's
party right right right which she was
wrong about too lisa's like oh for four
of this season it's only actually
nothing nevertheless she will persist
but i just feel like her presence on the
show is feeling more and more
superfluous like
yeah
because she went through a weird period
where she was like villainville and
villain and then she just stopped yeah
because she like was tired of you know
putting the show on her back with lisa
vanderpump but then when lisa vanderpump
left she like picked her her villain
stuff back up yeah she's really going
hard this season i think her and erica
are like you know what people don't like
us let's just say what we think i will
say like i did cringe when diana was
like oh you need a new villain
you knew here i am it's like
ew
it was like cringy yeah no and the
conversation with
i think sutton was really trying to
relate to diana sutton's mistake was
starting the conversation with you're
gonna have to clear up how you said
you're on bedrest and now suddenly poof
you're here because it came off
insensitive and then that's why diana
just like went full force like [ __ ]
but it's a valid question you texted
everyone you're not coming that you're
on bed rest
you walk into the party then you rsap to
sutton's dinner party and you said i
can't come now i'm on bed rest like it's
confusing yeah that's true it is
confusing yeah and kyle was like really
[ __ ] pissing me off this entire
episode like that scene
at garcelle's party where diana and kyle
are literally like first of all kyle was
like getting really physical with
suddenly i am shoving her and like
holding her arms really strong it was
really pissing me off it was like let
her speak and also it was just a crazy
response to be like no you didn't
yeah two miscarriages just cause you
don't know something doesn't mean it's
not true obviously and even her apology
at that italian restaurant that looked
so [ __ ] delicious oh my god what was
what she ordered the pepper
yeah it was like she got in the oaky
sutton and she got penne alas
she said it italian they you know what i
was actually thinking because uh
kyle like said it with an italian accent
and sun said it was southern accent
what do you think is better to put on an
accent for the place you're ordering
from or to say it in your own voice i
think of fusion like i would never say
can i have gnocchi but i would also
never say can i have nokia i'd be like
can i have gnocchi like my own fusion of
it yeah like okay can i i would never
say can i have a pennela vodka but i
would also never say can i have penny
vodka so can i have the penny alla vodka
like uh
you're using ones where there's um give
me another example
uh say you wanted to get um
hold on i'm trying to think like snails
like escargot foie gras foie gras so i
would never say like can i have the foie
gras i'd be like and i would never say i
can have the foie gras
yeah i love the foie gras okay what if
it's like haircut verts which are spring
beans okay well i don't know like how to
pronounce that like okay i don't know
how to print when i would take it i was
like
that's what i say too yeah yeah how
about like if it's like penne pomodoro
or whatever i'm i'll say like the
pasta with tomato no i'll say a penny
okay so here's
always easy to say but like if it's like
um
you know i'll read the ingredients and
then i'll say
i'd have the bolognese please i'll have
the pasta with meat sauce you would say
that not for that specifically but
sometimes
sometimes i'll just try and translate
and just speak yeah you know i guess
it's a case by case it is i also don't
eat like a really fancy foreign like
exquisite dishes yeah so i don't find
myself in that situation but i will say
may i have a parmigiano reggiano on the
side please yeah parm
parmigiano reggiano yeah
yeah what were we talking about how
delicious the restaurant they were oh my
god but how kyle's apology was like
actually true she was like yelling at
her and everyone just walks all over a
sudden and also it's like every new
person who enters the group comes for
sutton because yeah like diana said she
is easy no she has like weirdness about
her yes and diana was like
in all of she said something interesting
she was like
i know humans and like there's something
off about and there's she's quirky yeah
she is but crystal had the same
experience with her last season realized
she's just a nice person who just like
says things in a weird way and like does
things in a weird way but like is a very
well-meaning person and i'm sure as a
well-meaning person it's so frustrating
to constantly like never get the benefit
of the doubt from people first meeting
yeah you know brian moylan's like thing
made a
a really good point which was that like
everyone was mad at kyle this episode
because also when they were recapping um
erica talking about garcelle's sons kyle
was like it was funny but it was like
not funny and kyle wasn't even there the
person who was there the whole time was
to read who was like hysterically
laughing and it's like everyone was
literally tweeting at netflix like
cancel kyle's show but it's like kyle
was not even impressed i thought it was
because of the um the miscarriage but
also because she like didn't think it
was wrong what erica did to the kids it
was like dory was like fully sitting
there the entire episode yeah but she
was like trying to um she was like
navigating yeah she was like laughing
but also being like no stop but you're
also you know what it's like to be with
like that drunk friend there's no
talking sense into that person there's
only trying to diffuse it is garcelle's
friend cheray becoming like a friend of
we're getting like a lot of her yeah i
think she's like i actually really like
her and she is friendly i think with
sutton just because garcelle
hangs out with sutton so much and i just
need like more women to like believe
sutton and like trust sutton yeah we
need more we need to
balance scales yeah
garcelle is just like
she's everything of the sword although
the denise of it all
what's that denise didn't come to the
party
and so they were erica was like well
she's literally not your friend like you
keep like trying and she's not your
friend i don't think it's that i think
she doesn't want to be around these
women i agree i think they are very much
friends and she definitely doesn't want
to be on camera i don't think garcelle
cares whether denise comes to her party
that's like a production party she did
rsvp so it's like it's weird
i also think things are different when
you're filming reality tv sorry yes yes
yes for sure
um and then sutton's dinner party like
in the mud like although it was
incredibly annoying i felt like everyone
was complaining the whole oh yeah people
just wanted to make her look bad and
like the fact that she turned it around
and gave everyone fur coats and sandals
was so cute and made it like even cooler
yeah but everyone was just complaining
about everything like the ground my
shoes the food like it was like kind of
annoying yeah it's rude i will say i
understand why brandon didn't want to
wear her shoes on them because those
shoes are everything i just didn't know
why sutton didn't literally just pick up
the entire table and put it on the porch
like she seemed about dining outside
also
she should have had more food you can't
just do a salad as a main course
we're coming all the way for lunch and
it's just like there should be food
about i don't i don't like when people
don't have like you know plenty of food
yeah and that people come to an event
that's a meal and leave hungry and it's
definitely a cultural thing like if you
go to a jewish meal like you're
literally leaving with bags of food yeah
um and she's southern and i feel like
it's like a similar
culture yeah so that just felt odd
caviar appetizer is a salad for
the horse and then and everyone's
drinking
yeah
um and a bread basket i do like her
house i was gonna ask you what you
thought i don't love like the outside
like the actual architecture of the
house but i do really like her style
even though the one thing that bothered
me were her floors and i know she's like
and maybe this is just me being like
trash there when we restored the
original floors from 1930 and like while
that sounds really nice like ew your
floors are 100 years old and they're
like parquet which are my least favorite
style you know i have parquet i hate
them um it just didn't feel like very
elevated like sutton but her decor is
really beautiful i did like her old
house much better i agree with you it
didn't like she's been working on this
house for so long she's been living in
kyle's old house like in sutton as we
know like
just found out she owns a minor league
baseball team like she's a woman of
means no expense spared and
i was just like oh that's really nice
pretty house yeah it was just like
honestly i would put it on the same
level as like derates no and and it's
like a dead ass like a rental that you
literally move into like toothbrush like
everything but
like so modern and suns is literally the
polar opposite 100 years ago but
also she had her event in her backyard
but like that can't be the whole
backyard no i don't know it was just a
patch of grass i just loved her old
house it was so like southern and like
it was it was like kind of like a rage
parcel vibe like patterns yes i really
liked it i think it was too much house
for her no and i think that was a house
that she had with her husband so like
she went and i totally understand that
but this one was just like
that's how i felt too and don't get me
wrong i live in a thousand square foot
rental um
but i'm a watcher and viewer of
housewives and i'm allowed to judge what
do you think about dianna's house
um
it's like pretty it's not my particular
style it's so modern it's like so cold
and is the 87 million dollar house that
she sold the kardashians yes
so when lisa brandon was talking about
the view from her malibu house that is
the house and the final season of
kardashians during kobe that they rented
to like all be together yeah 87 million
dollars
why did she sell that house i don't know
because this
and i can't remember if every time she
shows us her one of her like the house
is she in the same house every time we
see her her in her house because she has
so many houses she has two in la i think
she is she's in this like modern it's
like a modern treehouse yeah i don't
like it it's a very you know selling
sunset yes if you could live in any of
the beverly hills housewives houses
whose would you live in let's go through
all of them kyle of course kyle's is
very nice meet you darite is modern not
my style
um garcelle is also pretty modern
oh crystal's house is sickening yeah
she's a huge she looks like all over a
cliff yeah
yeah yeah i think i might take crystals
or kyle's i love kyle's like property
her backyard i also like kyle's old
house i know she likes it too which one
is that the one that sutton was living
in no i didn't like that ranch style i
hated that house no i feel like she had
such it had good energy oh my god brian
moylan also said the funniest thing
and it was like how teddy mellencamp
like squeezes her way into any scene
that kyle is hosting and it's like where
is faye resnick and what did teddy
mellencamp do with her body because it's
like she really has replaced fae as like
the person hanging on to
someone's car alarm is going off outside
shut the [ __ ] up they're wondering where
fae is yeah
and no matter how many chanel bags you
borrow you will never be a lighting
yeah i like kyle's new houses come
together really nicely yes it's a little
like hodgepodge like the neon sign in
the in the foyer and it's just like a
lot yeah but for the most part i
actually really like her we have to wrap
the show there's literally like i don't
know and we're done talking anyway but
also i think faye designed did all her
interior she did the interior for the og
house the old house but i remember when
she moved into this house it took a
while and like for a while she was
living like kind of like
a college kid with like couch coffee
table tv yeah um but she had said that
faye was doing it yeah um we have to
wrap up the show because someone is
literally and we have to go be models oh
yeah so we'll be uh back tomorrow in
studio for the final episode of the week
thank you so much for listening to the
morning jasmine i'm only show where we
deliver the five stories that you need
to know every monday through friday on
youtube so if you're watching so youtube
please feel free to subscribe give me a
thumbs up okay let's just wrap the show
the alarm is so annoying bye everyone
love you